TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome to The Developer Show.
This week, we're backstage
at the Ubiquity Dev Summit.
Now remember to use the
nav bar at the bottom
to skip to your favorite
topic at any point.
Let's start with the TL;DR.
Check out the new
Android Emulator.
An early preview
is available today
to help you test your app on
more screen sizes and hardware
configurations than
you have at hand.
This update contains a
bunch of speed, performance,
and usability improvements.
Twitter used Doze mode
to improve notification
performance, and you can too.
Check out this blog
post for more details.
Removing the friction
of sign-in with Smart
Lock For Passwords increases
user re-engagement,
monetization
opportunities, and provides
cross-device analytics.
Check out this blog
post for what's new
and how to implement today.
Google Cloud Messaging
handles 150 billion messages
per day for over
750,000 applications,
and it keeps getting better.
Take a look at this post for
all the latest, including
unlimited free
topics for your app
and a new suite of server APIs.
A new Google Play
Services SDK is
available with custom email
app invites, Fused Location
Provider updates, and
maps API improvements,
plus a whole lot more.
Hit the link below to
learn all about it.
Now in beta, Trial Run Ads
and Interactive Interstitials.
All to help you get more
installs for you app.
Take advantage of
January's surge
in user activity on mobile
with Double Click's most
actionable research
and best practices.
Map your existing expertise
to the Google Cloud Platform
with this new White Paper.
And if you want to learn all
about the Google Cloud Platform
directly from
those who built it,
come to GCP Next 2016
in San Francisco.
Registration is open now.
Over the next couple
days, we're going
to interview some of the
coolest people speaking here
at the Ubiquity Dev Summit, and
you have an all-access pass.
So let's get to it.
OK, so here I am with
Gayathri Rajan, Vice President
of Product at Brillo and Weave.
Hi, Gayathri.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: She just
got offstage for the keynote
here at the Ubiquity Dev Summit.
Now for all the detail, people
can go to the keynote video.
It'll be linked below.
However, if you could just
give us a quick highlight,
what was the main takeaway
from your talk this morning?
GAYATHRI RAJAN: What
we've done at Google
is we've launched two platforms
for IOT, Brillo and Weave.
And we've done this
because we believe
that it's really important to
get a few of the basics, right?
Because these could
hinder adoption.
The two important
concerns we have
are interoperability
and security.
So what we've done is
built the elements directly
into the platform so it's
really easy for device makers
and developers out there to
build secure interoperable
devices.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now I'm
standing here with Chandu Thota,
Director of Engineering for
Geo and Local here at Google.
Hi, Chandu.
CHANDU THOTA: Hi, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So this morning
you talked about Beacons
during the keynote.
If you could give us one
key takeaway from your talk,
what would it be?
CHANDU THOTA: I think the
fundamental thing is Beacons
are these wonderful,
one-way transmitters that
are built to provide context
to your mobile apps, right?
And we have released
one as a platform
on top of this
hardware to provide you
this open specification of
frame formats, mobile SDKs that
work on both iOS and Android.
And also the
proximity Beacons are
released as a cloud service that
provides you with any storage
and serving requirements
of your metadata.
So all of this neatly comes
together with a single package
that developers need to
use to provide context
to their mobile apps.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Thank you, Chandu.
Now remember for
the whole story,
check out the links
in the description.
So I'm standing here with
Bret McGowen, a Developer
Advocate on the
Google Cloud Platform,
in the middle of Cloud Spin.
Bret, what is Cloud Spin?
BRET MCGOWEN: What
it is in a nutshell
is it reproduces special
effects you might see in movies
like "The Matrix,"
where someone jumps up
or they're frozen in air, and
it looks like the camera is
spinning around them.
We thought this would be
a fun and interactive way
to teach people about the cloud.
We used all off-the-shelf
components like Android,
we used Firebase to
synchronize everything,
we used App Engine to scale.
And we hope that it's
an interesting project
to rather than just tell
developers about what
the cloud can do, to actually
show them and hopefully inspire
them.
And show them a little bit that
no matter what crazy idea you
might have-- such as reproducing
this wacky special effect-- you
can do it with the power of
the Google Cloud Platform.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, should we give it a spin?
BRET MCGOWEN: All
right, let's do it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK.
And now we're over to
Wayne at the after party.
WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi,
I'm Wayne Piekarski,
and I'm here at the demos area
of the Ubiquity Conference.
And so today, I've got
Caitlin Johnson with me,
who's a Brillo Product Manager.
And today, we're
going to go check out
some of the really cool
demos that are here.
So let's go take a look.
MIKE LEE: So we
made a holiday tree
that has a LED star where
you can change the image.
These are individually
addressable,
so you could have any
kind of pattern you want.
But right now, it's just on
some random lights and colors.
ELLY NATTINGER: So
right now, this is all
running on the Brillo platform.
But what we haven't done
yet is gotten the chance
to look it up to Weave.
So next step is get that
internet connectivity,
get it that you push a button
on your phone and the lights
change color.
VENKAT PATNALA:
In this demo, I'm
going to show you how
the blinds have learned
to open when there's light.
So we have an app for the demo,
and it's in automatic mode
right now.
So I'll show you if
I turn on the light,
the blinds open slowly,
adjusting to your preferences.
GREGORY PRISAMENT: Hi.
So this is our prototype
of a smart water flow meter
that we made using
Brillo and Weave.
We went from idea to a working
prototype in 30 days using
Brillo and Weave.
It has an Edison board
running the Brillo OS,
talking to Weave in the cloud.
And we created this frontend
that actually shows you
how much water you're using
in a very intuitive way,
showing you each shower event
and how many gallons you
used during that event.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm
standing with Dan Shapiro,
the CEO of Glowforge.
Welcome to the show, Dan.
DAN SHAPIRO: Thanks
for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You just
did an amazing fireside chat
with Julia Ferraioli,
you've got to check out
this video for all the details.
But just real quick,
can you give us
a description-- for
the handful of people
in the audience
that don't yet know
what Glowforge is-- what is it?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah, it's
a 3D laser printer.
Basically, it uses
laser technology
to cut and engrave materials
like leather, wood, even paper
or chocolate.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And one of the
cool things about Glowforge--
and what we've been talking
about at the conference--
is the backend is the
Google Cloud Platform.
Can you tell us a
little why you chose
to use a cloud platform as a
backend for a desktop product?
DAN SHAPIRO: Yeah,
this is a technology
that's been around since
the '80s, CNC laser cutting
and engraving.
And the question
for us was how we
could bring the cost way down,
make it really easy to use,
and build it in a timeframe that
was reasonable for a start-up.
Instead of building a
really complex firmware that
could manage all the
commands locally,
or doing a local
client application that
would run on a computer and
would require constant updates
and compatibility
across multiple OSes,
we wanted to push as much
as possible into the cloud.
So you get at it
through a browser,
everything happens in
the cloud, and then
it pushes down to the
machine only the very barest
essentials, the actual
pulse files that
are fed out to the motors.
That means we can develop
and innovate really quickly,
it works across lots
of different platforms,
we can actually deliver a
great experience no matter
what sort of hardware
the user's using,
and it's much less expensive
for us to make the device
because we don't have to
build huge computing resources
into the local hardware.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: For
those of us that
might have missed
the Kickstarter,
when can I buy one?
DAN SHAPIRO: So you can
order right now-- pre-order
right now-- at Glowforge.com.
And we'll be shipping-- well,
folks who've already ordered
are getting their shipments
the first half of this year.
For new orders, coming out
second half of this year.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Thanks so much, Dan.
DAN SHAPIRO: Thanks
for having me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The Ubiquity
Dev Summit is winding down,
and so is this episode
of The Developer Show.
As always, check out the
links below for everything
that we've talked
about, including
the playlist to all the
sessions that happened here.
And of course, if you
have any questions for us,
use the hashtag #AskDevShow.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.